what do most Americans think about when
they think of sweet music the Muppets
maybe but I'd put my money on something
else
the iconic Swedish model whenever they
profile the Swedes they always seem to
be so happy and beautiful but there's
another Swedish model that's almost as
admired the Swedish economic model
compared to most other nations Sweden is
a success story but why is Sweden
successful many credit Sweden's generous
welfare state and progressive policies
with creating a standard of living that
is among the best in the world can the
rest of the world learn from Sweden if
you if you are willing to yes many think
we should be more like them if an
American would tell me that you know the
US should be more like Sweden I would
say I don't think it's possible dr.
Charlotte Eastern is a sociologist at
Stockholm University the u.s. is a very
diverse society whereas sweetness is or
at least has been up to modern times
very homogeneous people have looked the
same had the same religion they speak
the same language and good luck trying
to learn the language this is my first
tune it's spoken only by the nine
million people of Sweden a tiny group
compared to the US population of 300
million and Swedes typically don't move
far from the towns where they grew up
it's a cozy little country that might be
thought of as a close-knit Club well
club Sweden I think can be described as
sort of a very similar to what goes on
in small towns where you don't
necessarily recognize every single
person you meet on the street but where
it takes a very short time to establish
common grounds it makes for a friendlier
government something Stern has
experienced firsthand I lived up on a
big hill and I walked down to the subway
every day and I and I could never find a
mailbox so she sent an email asking
public officials to install a mailbox in
a more convenient location and guess
what they did a postal worker even
invited her to the grand opening
and she asked me if I could actually
come and cut the ribbon don't bet on
getting that kind of service from the US
Postal Service American bureaucracies
just don't inspire much trust it's the
high trust that sweets have in each
other that makes it possible to build an
extensive welfare state America could
pass laws that mimic Sweden's welfare
state policies but it's tough to
replicate a culture that allows those
policies to work about as smoothly as
possible but America could emulate some
of the Swedish policies that don't
require extensive bureaucracies every
morning stern helps her daughter Rebecca
get ready for school yeah I think it's a
mother
the most important aspect actually for
me is that my daughter is happy I like
my school very much most aspects of
Swedish schooling would be familiar to
Americans oh I just really like the
spelling who's this Yosef guy here that
there are even the inevitable schoolyard
romances I love fun but there's a big
difference Rebekah uses a voucher to
attend a private school you now have a
choice to sort of seek out a school
that's that you feel is the right one
for your kid u.s. teachers unions regard
vouchers as free-market radicalism but
families and progressive Sweden enjoy
universal school choice it's one of the
many things that would surprise
Outsiders says economist dr. andreas
Berg some people feel that Sweden grew
rich because of social democracy or
labour unions but that's not the reason
Sweden grew rich Sweden grew rich like
any country that is rich through
well-functioning capitalist institutions
work trade innovation that says Berg is
what transformed the poverty-stricken
Sweden at the late 19th century into one
of the world's richest nations by the
time a certain foursome started singing
but then Sweden changed course and
adopted the progressive policies that
made it famous
however after years of economic
sluggishness Sweden altered its
direction again in the 1990s
many free market reforms from school
choice to deregulation there have been
new regulations of basically everything
from taxi air services railroads
electricity telecommunications
the most important thing is is that you
lower the top marginal tax rates that
used to be around 80 percent it's still
high tax level but it's no longer very
progressive and and that's a big change
although much of the 70s era welfare
state remains bared credits the free
market reforms with turning the economy
around Sweden is moving in the market
economic direction but that does not
mean that the United States should be
moving in the socialist direction a
childish I'd some of my free-market
principles
Sweden's debt has been shrinking in
recent decades but not so for ours it
keeps growing and growing health
insurance reform became the law of the
land and we emulate Sweden's welfare
state programs even though they'll
likely flounder and a giant population
where bureaucracies don't engender trust
you can't just build up this whole Club
Sweden experience in a culture that is
so different from the Swedish culture so
what will happen if Sweden and America
continue on in different directions well
maybe someday when America is looking
for a way to rejuvenate its economy
pundits will say we should emulate a
different kind of Swedish model for
reason TV I'm Ted Bala kur